eh bien j'ai l'impression qu'on est un
peu en train de partager un sentiment de
malaise
non non clairement les poils c'est
vraiment début de manière différente
alors qu'on est d'accord que plus ou
moins tout le monde n'avait jusque là et
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai une femme ça va
être vu comme quelque chose de sale ou
des associés à de la négligence du
laisser aller
quoique ça veut dire alors que chez un
homme c'est plus tranquille je sais pas
vous monsieur par exemple si vous vous
êtes déjà fait insulter à la piscine
parce que vous étiez pas été les mois
oui et pourquoi cette différence
moi je suis responsable de ce que je
fais de mon corps je suis pas
responsable de ce que les autres en
pensent qu'on voit l' enveloppe
corporelle de quelqu'un on va réagir de
manière conforme à nos codes à nos
croyances avec ce avec quoi on a été
élevé nous mêmes pourtant il faut bien
voir que c'est pas du tout quelque chose
qui a toujours été comme ça
ce qui hélas ce qu'est la beauté ce
qu'est le rapport au corps normal c'est
quelque chose qui va complètement évolué
en fonction des cultures d époque les
femmes vont trouver absolument canon il
ya 400 ans ont pas grand chose à voir
avec nous en choeur d'aujourd'hui auquel
on est amené à se comparer et quasiment
constamment et si c'était à la société
d'évoluer
et si ce n'était pas à nous de changer
si le problème c'était les codes c'était
les normes et c'est pas nos corps le
problème
je pense qu'il est possible d'interagir
de manière différente avec ses codes là
on peut en jouer on peut les détourner
on peut les contourner on peut faire
semblant qu'il n'existe pas c'est pas
toujours évident
j'admets mais c'est important de
permettre aux gens de laisser faire ça
permettre une meilleure liberté
d'expression de qui on veut montrer à
l'autre
comment on apparaît tester différentes
identités différentes manières de se
montrer et c'est important de pouvoir
interagir avec le monde de manière
différente
moi j'ai décidé de ne pas attendre qu'on
me donne l'autorisation d'être
extraordinaire je m'entends pas
extraordinaire pour faire le show devant
vous aujourd'hui être extraordinaire
parce que on m'a plus laisser le choix
parce que des fois à vivre avec les
codes vivre avec des normes qu'on n'a
pas choisi qui nous correspondent pas du
tout ça peut être extrêmement douloureux
et ça vient de la survie en général
d'aller à son encontre parce que
s'affranchir des codes c'est pas quelque
chose de facile à vivre au quotidien
c'est se mettre face à de l'agressivité
à de l'incompréhension à la violence
parfois mais pourquoi est ce que notre
apparence serait à ce point là un
problème aux yeux d'autrui pourquoi est
ce que selon si on apparaît devant vous
comme une femme comme un homme on aura
des attentes absolument différente sur
ce qu'il est temps de se libérer du
système de pensée binaire pour le corps
ce qui le corps qui va être bien qui va
être mauvais qui va être moche qui va
être beau ce qui va apparaître comme
féminins ou masculins
en tout cas j'ai décidé de plus vraiment
me sentir concerné
du coup ça fait des exemples un peu
absurde et fois ou si je porte une
grande chemise pas de maquillage et
pendant longtemps j'ai eu les cheveux
très très court bain chez le coiffeur
j'avais une chance sur deux si j'étais
en short de payer le tarif sommes
tellement c'est compliqué pour beaucoup
de concevoir que l'on peut être une
femme et avoir des poils dans le métro
pareil avec les cheveux très courts pas
de maquillage vous la différence quand
les gens vous prennent pour un homme il
voulait se passait dans le métro nous
font de l'espace sans même vous jetez un
regard sans faire un commentaire sur la
manière dont je suis à bille ou pourquoi
est-ce que je saurai pas à 8h30 dans le
métro parisien et ça c'est vraiment un
exemple par ligne et moi si je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est parce que moi aussi
première fois j'ai rencontré une femme
dans le métro qui s'était pas épilée je
vais pas vous mentir j'ai été dégoûté
je lève les yeux de mon livre et je la
vois et vraiment ça m'a fait aimer un
tel bouleversement un tel choc que ça
m'a rappelé à moi même pourquoi est ce
que je ressentais autant de sentiments
négatifs pour le corps de quelqu'un
d'autre
pourquoi est ce que je ressentais autant
de sentiments négatifs pour mon propre
corps et pourquoi je devrais avoir honte
aujourd'hui d'avoir le corps que j'ai
elle m'a permis de remettre en question
tout le système de pensée avec lequel
j'avais évolué et pour ça lui dit merci
je pense qu'on peut tous se donner
l'autorisation d'être qui en veux être
moi aujourd'hui j'ai un projet qui
s'appelle la chronique qui une chaîne
youtube et des ateliers d'éducation aux
sexualités pour les adolescents et les
adolescentes pour leur proposer d'autres
modèles qui soit celui proposé par la
norme pour leur proposer d'autres
visions du rapport à l'autre des
relations du rapport à son propre corps
pour leur permettre de repousser les
lignes et d'expérimenter en dehors de ce
qui est vu comme normal lorsque chacun
de mieux se sentir à l'aise comme ça
avec sa copine notre corps on en a
hérité
on l'a pas choisi il a évolué en
fonction du temps des circonstances de
ce qu'on a fait avec et je pense que le
corps est pas là pour être beau je pense
que le corps est pas là pour plaire aux
autres pour plaire à personne en réalité
pourquoi effet le corps si ce n'est pour
vivre dedans du mieux qu'on peut
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]